let's talk about your podcast the sarah
silverman podcast congratulations you're
the perfect person to be doing a podcast
uh and i would just imagine you've got
such a funny creative
quick brain you know everybody you've
got a million stories
this is the perfect thing for you to be
doing right now thanks
well he said it all i want to thank
conan for being here
and for promoting uh my podcast the
sarah silverman podcast
do you like what are you finding that
you uh like most about doing it
i like just uh i like
how messy it is i like how loose it is
i just gab and then you know we i i
elicit illicit
is that the voice i don't you have to
say the whole sentence until i can tell
you if it's the right word or not
i elicit voicemails from people
sure so i would think it would be maybe
solicit or i encourage
people to send in their voicemails
what's illicit well elicit like i elicit
a response
uh my my out my my outrageous remarks
elicited
strong condemn condemnation uh from the
politburo
what the hell was that mansplaining yeah
i'm sorry
no i asked you i know i love it when a
woman asks me a question
and then i say what i think it is and
then they say thanks for mansplaining
that's a good trap yeah i was trapping
you um
i uh solicit you solicit
i don't think that's good on its own i
solicit i ask
for voicemails on my social media
streams
people call in and leave voicemails then
um
the producer diana listens to all of
them
picks about 20 or so and then the night
before we listen to it
and we pick about five or six and i
don't necessarily know exactly what i'll
say but i go yeah this will be good you
know
and then um usually i get in i talk
about whatever little micro
thing and then uh we play the
voicemails and that really dictates the
direction of the podcast
and then before you know it it's over
it's over and uh
what's nice is you're free of all this
strict professionalism of an interview
like this
it is funny though this is so
constraining let me ask you i want to
see the real you not this uptight
yeah rehearse this is so rehearsed
when i i'm i maybe you
relate to this on anyway i don't know
when i started the podcast i thought you
know i've been
i knew it would be a learning curve it's
a new medium but
also i've been a public speaker for many
you know for decades now you know right
but it's
it's funny to me i had to learn a lot of
the stuff i learned in stand-up a long
time ago like
over again like the first few episodes i
said the f word
every other word whatever
right right i'm listening back and it's
like such
it's so league you know yeah and i had
to learn like all right i think i was so
excited about the total
freedom and you know it just comes off
like a crutch like you've got to make it
a treat or have a purpose for it or like
very decidedly no purpose for it
whatever but
you know i had to learn that again and
then also i was like why aren't people
writing think pieces about this
not that i was saying that but you know
what i mean like i wanted like
and then i was in the tub but i took a
puff and i thought about it and i go
that's so embarrassing like the one
thing i tell young young comedians like
don't look for an agent to come see you
right away or whatever just keep your
head down do stand up
and when you're good people will be
talking about you and only like it's
like in a pit
like this ridiculous epiphany that i
know better
to just like work do this podcast and
work on it and make it better each time
i'm still figuring it out
but here i am on conan just to get a few
more
um subscribers what do you mean a few
more you're gonna
you're gonna triple your numbers being
on this show a few more
this is gonna put you through the roof
kid this is a rocket to success this
show
i know as tigg says i think i'm gonna
maybe i'll get discovered did she still
see it does tinotara still say that
maybe i'll get discovered because i
think i'm gonna get discovered tonight
yeah i don't think anyone's said that
about in show business in like 50 years
listen uh you're the perfect person to
be doing a podcast i'm excited that
you're doing this do you like doing the
ads
i do like doing the ads i don't know why
right i don't know what it is and maybe
it's like from listening to howard
or just listening to podcasts yeah well
he does he's the master
but also he you know howard stern i've
been listening to him for years
yeah and that it doesn't corrupt
his comedy or his point of view at all
he'll he'll talk about whatever he wants
to talk about and he'll say
hey and by the way if you're looking for
window shades and i'll think yes
i am looking for window shades i know i
bought things from
i got two squatty potties for my dad on
father's day a few years ago
he was he was from he was pushing
squatty potties for a while
why two i don't know i just thought
um does one go on top of the other is
that is that thing does that
move things along even faster if you add
more squatty potty like if you had five
squatty potties would you just empty
your bowels in a second
you know what i think i bought him too
because i do know that he only
he's designated one bathroom between the
two bathrooms they have
you know um for doing that but um
i think it's because it was nine dollars
and i felt cheap getting
one yeah but then it's just 18
right well i'm glad you know what you
just did now you worked in an ad for
squatty potty
that's true i wish we could show the
animation that explains exactly how it
works
i like coming up with theme songs i like
you know what it's fun and also i just
think that
like when you're given limits
there is something about having no
limits on your podcast so when you do
have limits
it forces you to be creative like like
all the
limits look at this look at your
audience that's what happens when you
have limits you come up with
weird creative comedy finds away stuff
exactly it's the limits that let us grow
yeah i mean just blue sky is like
paralyzing
exactly i think we've learned a lot in
this interview you want to have a
push-up contest i can only do one
i think i would win how many can you do
a lot more than one
a lot more well i'm a man aren't i
[Laughter]
well and also three is 300 of one
yeah so he's doing a triple i didn't say
that i would be
uh a functioning human being after i did
them
i mean we can't touch right because
another thing we could do is the three
of us could make a pyramid
can't do it people would write in and
say we'd get you know fauci writing in
saying
no pyramids i said also because i'm
scared i'm so scared of getting it
i would i would in the pyramid thing i
would insist on being the top
i would insist on you being the top i
think thank you
you'd have to be the top about the time
about time i got known as a top
well you know see this is the kind of
strict professionalism you need to
escape with the podcast
andy presents as a bottom but he's a top
thank you well anyway
welcome to things my parents won't
understand
you can listen to the sarah silverman
podcast on itunes and wherever
podcasts are available and you're going
to listen to it
i'm thrilled so delighted that you came
here in person that i was dancing in the
parking lot before you arrived here
thank you i'm so tired of zoom and i
love you
and you being here in person is just
christmas come early
i know that's a big holiday for you so
sarah silverman thank you very much
we're gonna say merry christmas again
yeah yeah every single year
look i'm kicking a mussolini's head i
kick a tear and i kick it